WHATEVER HOUR IT IS.
IT’LL BE GOOD FOR THE COUNTRY.
WE BEGIN WITH THE FOX NEWS
ALERT.
WE ARE TRACKING MULTIPLE
BREAKING STORIES.
PRESIDENT HOLDING A RALLY,
PRETTY RAUCOUS, IN IOWA TONIGHT.
OH, AND JOE ONLY GOT 75 PEOPLE.
QUID PRO QUO JOE.
WE WILL TAKE YOU THERE LIVE IN A
MOMENT.
WE ARE CONTINUING TO MONITOR THE
QUESTION AND ANSWER PHASE OF THE
IMPEACHMENT CHARADE, YES, THAT’S
GOING ON AS WE SPEAK.
WE WILL DIP IN AND OUT.
FIRST TONIGHT, THE PRESIDENT HAS
EVERY REASON TO BE GLAD AND
HAPPY.
IT’S ABOUT TO BE GAME OVER.
WHAT IS THE DEMOCRATS LATEST
SCHEME?
BY ALL ACCOUNTS, CHUCK SCHUMER,
THE DEMOCRATS DO NOT HAVE THE
VOTES TO KEEP IT GOING ANY
LONGER.
TODAY HE SAID IT WOULD BE AN
UPHILL FIGHT.
KEEP IN MIND, THIS IS VERY
IMPORTANT.
THE MOB AND THE MEDIA WON’T TELL
YOU.
DURING QUENTIN’S SENATE TRIAL
THERE WERE NO NEW WITNESSES
CALLED, NONE.
JAY SEKULOW POINTED OUT ALL THE
WITNESSES CALLED IN THE SENATE
WERE PREVIOUSLY DEPOSED IN THE
HOUSE PROCEEDINGS OR GRAND JURY
PROCEEDINGS.
STILL, YOU HAVE THE COMPROMISE,
CORRUPT CONGENITAL LIAR
ADAM SCHIFF DESPERATE.
HE IS BEGGING AND PLEADING FOR
JUST A FEW DAYS OF NEW WITNESS
TESTIMONY WHICH AGAIN, LIKE
EVERYTHING ELSE HE’S DONE IS
UNPRECEDENTED.
LOOK AT YOUR SCREEN.
IN THE OPENING WEEK ON THE
SENATE FLOOR, SCHIFF STATED THE
CHARGES "HAD BEEN PROVED."
IN FACT, HERE’S THE EXACT
PHRASE.
"THAT HAVE BEEN PROVED" OVER AND
OVER AGAIN.
HIS COLLEAGUE JERROLD NADLER
SAID "ROCK-SOLID CASE THEY HAVE
NOW FOR IMPEACHMENT."
SO IF THEY PROVE THEIR
ROCK-SOLID CASE, WHY COULDN’T
THEY GET IS A REPUBLICAN IN
THE HOUSE AND WHY ARE THEY NOW
BEGGING SENATE REPUBLICANS TO
LITERALLY TAKE OVER WHAT IS THE
CONSTITUTIONAL ROLE, THE SOLE
POWER, THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES TO IMPEACH?
WHY WOULD THEY GIVE BACK TO
THEM?
EVEN QUID PRO QUO JOE BIDEN, HE
GOT IT RIGHT AND HE ARGUED THIS
IN 1999 IN A TRIAL MEMO THAT "NO
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES OR EVIDENCE
WERE NEEDED IN ORDER TO ACQUIT."
WOW.
HYPOCRISY ABOUNDS.
ABC REPORTING THE WITCH HUNT
TRIAL COULD BE OVER BY EITHER
TOMORROW OR SATURDAY.
WHAT A WEEK COULD SPEND.
FOR THE PAST FOUR DAYS AND
NIGHTS, THE PRESIDENT’S LEGAL
TEAM HAS ABSOLUTELY OBLITERATED
AND DESTROYED THE DEMOCRATS’
BOGUS CASE, INCLUDING ONE
PARTICULAR MOMENT AND ACTUALLY
THERE WERE MANY WERE THEY
CORRUPT CONGENITAL LIAR
ADAM SCHIFF WAS RIPPED TO SHREDS
BY THE PRESIDENT’S PERSONAL
ATTORNEY JAY SEKULOW.
WATCH THIS.
>> WE ARE TALKING ABOUT NOW
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES THAT THE
MANAGERS HAVE PUT FORWARD AND
THAT DEMOCRATIC LEADER SCHUMER
HAS DISCUSSED.
HE IS DISCUSSED FOUR WITNESSES
IN PARTICULAR, AS OF THIS BODY
-- IF IT WERE TO GRANT WITNESSES
WOULD SAY YES, YOU GET THOSE
FOUR WITNESSES AND THE
WHITE HOUSE AND THE PRESIDENT’S
COUNSEL GETS WHAT?
WHENEVER I WANT TO.
THAT’S WHAT HE SAID.
WHATEVER I WANT.
HERE’S WHAT I WANT.
I WANT ADAM SCHIFF.
I WANT HUNTER BIDEN.
I WANT JOE BIDEN.
I WANT THE WHISTLE-BLOWER.
THEY PUT THIS FORWARD IN AN
AGGRESSIVE AND FAST-PACED WAY,
AND NOW THEY ARE SAYING NOW WE
NEED WITNESSES.
AFTER 31 OR 32 TIMES YOU SAID
YOU PROVED EVERY ASPECT OF YOUR
CASE.
THAT’S WHAT YOU SAID.
JEFF SAID HE DID.
THEN I DON’T THINK WE NEED ANY
WITNESSES.
>> Sean: CHECK, GAME OVER, THE
DEMOCRATS ARGUMENT IS ALMOST NOW
TO -- TOO INSANE TO BE TRUE.
CLAIMING THEIR ROCK-SOLID CASE
IS TALLY PROVEN BUT WE WANT
YOU TO BRING IN ABOUT HALF A
DOZEN NEW PEOPLE, MORE
WITNESSES, PEOPLE WE DIDN’T CALL
OR SUBPOENA TO PROVE OUR CASE,
IN ADDITION TO THE 18 PREVIOUS
WITNESSES SPOUTING HEARSAY AND
OPINION.
THERE WAS ONLY ONE FACT WITNESS
OF ALL THEIR WITNESSES.
DO YOU REMEMBER WHAT HE SAID?
WHAT DO YOU WANT, MR. PRESIDENT
NOTHING.
NO QUID OR PRO OR QUO, LIKE JOE.
HAVE YOU HEARD ANY THING SO
STUPID AND ENJOY LIFE?
EVEN NANCY PELOSI IS BEGINNING
TO SEE THE HANDWRITING ON THE
WALL AND SHE IS APOPLECTIC AND
FURIOUS AND EVEN BEGINNING A
MELTDOWN.
TAKE A LOOK.
SPEAK OF THE PRESIDENT’S TEAM IS
THERE TO DISMANTLE THE
CONSTITUTION OF THE UNITED STATE
HE WILL NOT BE ACQUITTED.
YOU CANNOT BE ACQUITTED IF YOU
DON’T HAVE A TRIAL.
IF YOU DON’T HAVE A TRIAL IF YOU
DON’T HAVE WITNESSES AND
DOCUMENTATION AND THAT.
I DON’T THINK THEY MADE THE
CASE.
I THINK THEY DISGRACED
THEMSELVES TERRIBLY IN TERMS OF
THEIR VIOLATION OF WHAT OUR
CONSTITUTION IS ABOUT AND WHAT A
PRESIDENT’S BEHAVIOR SHOULD BE.
>> Sean: DETACHED FROM REALITY
AGAIN, PRETTY SCARY, RAGE FILLED
FANTASYLAND.
THE PRESIDENT WILL NEVER BE
ACQUITTED.
WELL, THIS IS WHY VOTERS, WELL,
THEY SEE THROUGH THE CHARADE.
ALL OF THIS IS BUT THE
CULMINATION OF A THREE YEAR LONG
NONSTOP NEVER-ENDING TEMPER
TANTRUM BY DEMOCRATS WHO STILL
CANNOT ACCEPT THE WILL OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE FROM 2016.
IT’S ONLY THE LATEST REDUNDANT
CHAPTER, SAD CHAPTER, AND THE
NEVER-ENDING SMEAR CAMPAIGN
AGAINST THE PRESIDENT AS THEY DO
NOTHING FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
WE HAVE WITNESSES PHONY,
SELECTIVE, OUTRAGE HYPOCRISY
EVERY SECOND IN IT, HOUR OF
EVERY 24 A DAY.
IT’S NEVER BEEN A FACT-FINDING
MISSION OR ABOUT THE TRUTH AT
ALL.
IT’S BEEN RUN BY SOMEBODY WHO
HAS LIED TO THE COUNTRY FOR
THREE CONSECUTIVE YEARS, A FACT
WITNESSES CASE HIMSELF.
HE’S COMPROMISED.
THE CONGENITAL LIAR.
WE HAVE ALL THE PROOF WE NEED ON
RUSSIA, RUSSIA.
NO, WE DON’T.
TODAY LIKE EVERY DAY PRETTY MUCH
THEY SPEWED MORALIZE, INCLUDING
A BRAND-NEW TOTALLY INSANE
CONSPIRACY THEORY.
LET’S TAKE A LOOK AT THE LATEST
ONE.
>> LETS A RUDY GIULIANI DOES
ANOTHER ERRAND FOR THE
PRESIDENT, THIS TIME AN ERRAND
IN CHINA.
HE SAYS TO THE CHINESE WE WILL
GIVE YOU A FAVORABLE DEAL WITH
RESPECT TO CHINESE FARMERS AS
OPPOSED TO AMERICAN FARMERS.
WE WILL BETRAY THE AMERICAN
FARMER IN THE TRADE DEAL.
BUT HERE’S WHAT WE WANT.
THEY QUID PRO QUO IS WE WANT YOU
TO DO AN INVESTIGATION OF THE
BIDENS.
YOU KNOW THE ONE, THE WON THE
PRESIDENT HAS BEEN CALLING FOR.
THEY WOULD SAY THAT’S OKAY.
THEY WOULD SAY THAT’S A QUID PRO
QUO TO HELP HIS REELECTION.
HE CAN BETRAY THE AMERICAN
FARMER.
THAT’S OKAY.
>> Sean: HE IS A GUY WHO SAID
QUID PRO QUO JOE WHO SAID YOU’RE
NOT GETTING THE BILLING UNLESS
YOU FIRE THE PROSECUTOR
INVESTIGATING MY ZERO
EXPERIENCED SON BEING PAID
MILLIONS.
THEY WERE TOTALLY INNOCENT.
HE IS FANTASIZING ABOUT HIS
FAVORITE ANTI-TRUMP ANALOGY ON
THE SENATE FLOOR, AS HE REFUSES
TO EVEN DISCUSS THE ORIGINS OF
THE WITCH TRIAL, THE FAKE
WHISTLE-BLOWER THAT HE LIED
ABOUT IN THAT CASE, IN CASE YOU
FORGOT, THIS WHOLE ORDEAL
ALLEGEDLY STARTING BECAUSE
A STUNNING AND BRAVE DEEP STATE
BUREAUCRAT CAME FORWARD WITH AN
URGENT WARNING ABOUT
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
WE WOULD LOVE TO HEAR FROM THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER COME HE SAID,
THIS INDIVIDUAL FILES A
COMPLAINT WITH THE INTEL
COMMUNITIES.
INSPECTOR GENERAL.
IN THE SUBSEQUENT WEEKS, SCHIFF
VOWED TO BRING THIS PERSON AND
FOR IMPORTANT TESTIMONY AND HE
SAID WE HAVE NOT SPOKEN DIRECTLY
TO THE WHISTLE-BLOWER.
WE WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK TO THIS
PERSON.
I’M THEN EVERYTHING CHANGED
BECAUSE HE GOT EXPOSED, THE LIE,
WELL, WAS REVEALED.
IT SURFACED REPORTS THAT THE
SO-CALLED HEARSAY WHISTLE-BLOWER
WAS IN DIRECT CONTACT WITH HIS
OFFICE FROM THE GET-GO.
EVEN BEFORE THE COMPLAINT WAS
FILED.
THEN ALL OF A SUDDEN, YES, THE
CONGENITAL LIAR REFUSES TO ALLOW
THIS INDIVIDUAL TO TESTIFY THE
HOUSE.
EVEN MORE IMPORTANTLY, HE IS
STOPPING AND REFUSING, YOU WANT
DOCUMENTATION?
HE WON’T RELEASE THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL’S REPORT
SURROUNDING THIS INDIVIDUAL’S
COMPLAINT.
AND NOW HE REFUSES TO ADDRESS
ANY QUESTIONS ABOUT ANOTHER
REPORT CLAIMING THAT THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER, OH, HE WAS
ACTUALLY OVERHEARD AS AN OBAMA
HOLD OVER TWO WEEKS INTO THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION, EARLY
2017, DISCUSSING WITH ANOTHER
FELLOW DEEP STATE OBAMA HOLD
OVER GET RID OF TRUMP.
DESPITE A MOUNTAIN OF EVIDENCE
ABOUT THE FAKE HEARSAY
WHISTLE-BLOWER AND POLITICAL
BIAS AND SEE THE CONNECTIONS AND
CONNECTIONS TO THE CONGENITAL
LIAR’S OFFICE, APPARENTLY IS A
DELICATE FLOWER.
HE WHO MUST NOT EVER BE NAMED.
LORD GOLD MORT, THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER.
HE SHALL NEVER BE NAMED.
HE SHALL NEVER FACE ANY
QUESTIONS ABOUT HIS MOTIVES.
EVEN CHIEF JUSTICE ROBERTS,
WELL, HE DID THE DEMOCRATS’
BIDDING TODAY.
PRETTY SHAMEFUL IN MY VIEW, AND
REFUSED TO READ A QUESTION,
WELL, THAT POSSIBLY CONTAINED
THE ALLEGED IDENTITY OF THE
HEARSAY NONWHISTLE-BLOWER
WHISTLE-BLOWER WHO WAS IN
CONTACT WITH SCHIFF’S OFFICE.
AS THE PRESIDENT ATTORNEYS
POINTED OUT, THIS HEARSAY
WHISTLE-BLOWER HAS A LOT TO
ANSWER FOR.
WE WILL GET ANSWERS ONE DAY.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> IF THE WHISTLE-BLOWER, AS IS
ALLEGED IN SOME PUBLIC REPORTS
ACTUALLY DID WORK FOR THEM
VICE PRESIDENT BIDEN ON UKRAINE
ISSUES, EXACTLY WHAT WAS HIS
ROLE?
DID HE HAVE SOME REASON TO WANT
TO PUT THE DEEP SIX ON ANY
RAISING ANY ISSUE ABOUT WHAT
WENT ON WITH THE BIDENS AND
BURISMA AND FIRING VIKTOR SHOKIN
AND WITHHOLDING A BILLION
DOLLARS IN LOAN GUARANTEES
ENFORCEMENT A VERY EXPLICIT QUID
PRO QUO.
YOU WON’T GET THIS BILLION
DOLLARS INTO YOU FIRE HIM.
>> Sean: WHAT COMPANY WOULD
EVER PAY MILLIONS AND MILLIONS
FOR SOMEBODY WITH NO EXPERIENCE?
WHAT VICE PRESIDENT WHATEVER
DEMAND AND USE OUR TAX DOLLARS,
A BILLION OF THEM, AND SHAKE
DOWN THE COMPANY TO FIRE
PROSECUTOR AND YOU’VE ONLY GOT
SIX HOURS AND SON OF A B, THEY
DID IT.
BE CAREFUL WHAT YOU WISH FOR.
ADAM SCHIFF, IF ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES ARE CALLED, WELL, NOT
ONLY WILL YOUR PRECIOUS HEARSAY
WHISTLE-BLOWER GET NAMED, BUT
YOU WILL BE CALLED IN TO
TESTIFY.
BY THE WAY, EITHER WAY, QUID PRO
QUO JOE ZERO EXPERIENCED HUNTER
BEING PAID MILLIONS WITH NO
EXPERIENCE, AND THIS LITTLE
DOG AND PONY SHOW WILL END WITH
EVEN FURTHER EMBARRASSMENT.
EITHER WAY, THOSE THINGS MUST BE
INVESTIGATED.
THEY MUST BE AT THIS POINT.
NO MATTER WHAT, THE PRESIDENT
WILL BE VINDICATED.
WE ARE NOW JUST 278 DAYS UNTIL
THE ULTIMATE JURY, YOU, THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, YEP, YOU GET TO
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY.
YOU CAN SHOCK THE WORLD AGAIN.
THE PRESIDENT IS PICKING UP
MOMENTUM.
MOMENTS AGO WE HAD THIS TO SAY
ABOUT THE ENTIRE IMPEACHMENT
CHARADE.
LET’S TAKE A LOOK.
>> President Trump: YOU KNOW,
WE ARE HAVING PUMMELED THE BEST
YEARS WE’VE EVER HAD IN THE
HISTORY OF OUR COUNTRY --
PROBABLY THE BEST YEARS WE’VE
EVER HAD IN THE HISTORY OF OUR
COUNTRY.
AND I JUST GOT A PEACH.
CAN YOU BELIEVE THESE PEOPLE?
I GOT IMPEACHED.
POISONING OUR DEMOCRACY, THEY
WANT TO OVER THROW THE ENTIRE
SYSTEM OF GOVERNMENT.
THAT’S NOT HAPPENING.
I CAN TELL YOU THAT.
>> Sean: IT’S ONLY A MATTER OF
TIME BEFORE THE SCHUMER-SCHIFF
SHAM SHOW IS OVER AND THE
PRESIDENT IS ALREADY WINNING.
INTEGRATE NEW ARTICLE,
MOLLIE HEMINGWAY AT
"THE FEDERALIST" IDENTIFIED
EIGHT KEY REASONS WHY THE
SCHUMER-SCHIFF CHAMP SHOW IS A
BIG WON FOR THE PRESIDENT OF THE
BIG LOSER FOR DEMOCRATS.
ONE, IT’S CLEAR HE DID NOT
COMMIT ANY IMPEACHABLE OFFENSE.
NONE WERE EVEN IDENTIFIED.
THE ARTICLES DON’T LIST AN
IMPEACHABLE OFFENSE.
SECOND, DEMOCRATS HAVE BOTCHED
THIS CHARADE FROM THE BEGINNING.
WEIRD SOVIET STYLE TOP-SECRET
INVESTIGATION IN THE BASEMENT OF
THE HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES.
NO DUE PROCESS FOR THE PRESIDENT
AND HIS LAWYERS.
WE CAN WEAK, PATHETIC EVIDENCE.
HEARSAY WITNESSES, OPINION
WITNESSES, SECOND, THIRD HAND
ACCOUNT WITNESSES.
A SERIES OF ACCUSATIONS THAT
WERE DIFFICULT TO UNDERSTAND.
FIRST QUID PRO QUO.
NO, WE WILL CALL IT BRIBERY.
WE WON’T MEANT AND ANY OF THESE
THINGS IN THE ACTUAL ARTICLES.
THE DEMOCRATS GOT ZERO
REPUBLICAN SUPPORT, NONE
WHATSOEVER.
REMEMBER NANCY PELOSI SAID IT
HAD TO BE BIPARTISAN.
NOT BIPARTISAN.
FOUR, WE HAVE THE INEXPLICABLE
ONE-MONTH DELAY SENDING
IMPEACHMENT TO THE SENATE.
A WORD OF ADVICE FOR
NANCY PELOSI.
IF YOU’RE GOING TO RAM THROUGH
BECAUSE IT’S SO URGENT, TWO B.S.
ARTICLES OF IMPEACHMENT, RECORD
TIME.
NOT SUBPOENA THE WITNESSES THAT
YOU NOW THINK MAYBE YOU
SHOULD’VE SUBPOENAED ALL IN THE
NAME OF URGENCY, YOU MIGHT NOT
WANT TO PROCRASTINATE,
TRANSMITTING THE ARTICLES TO THE
SENATE BECAUSE IT KIND OF MAKES
IT LOOK LIKE YOU’RE LYING
BECAUSE HE DID IT JUST BEFORE
CHRISTMAS BECAUSE IT WAS URGENT.
SO YOU COULD GO ON VACATION.
AND THEN YOU GO ON VACATION AND
THEN YOU STILL DON’T WANT TO
HAND THEM OVER.
HOW URGENT WAS IT?
FIVE, THE PRESIDENT’S DEFENSE
TEAM ALL CREDIT BE DUE.
THEY HAVE DONE A SPECTACULAR AND
AMAZING JOB TOP TO BOTTOM.
SIX, HOUSE MANAGERS HAVE DONE
NOTHING BUT INSULT SENATORS AND
WE, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
NEVER ENDING, NONSTOP LYING
OUTRIGHT, INNUENDO.
BY THE WAY, PRETTY MUCH
EVERYTHING WE’VE GOTTEN FOR
THREE LONG YEARS AS THEY HAVE
DONE NOTHING BUT HATE THIS
PRESIDENT AND NOT SERVE THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE OR DO ANYTHING
FOR PEACE, PROSPERITY, JOB
CREATION.
NOTHING.
AND THE SAFETY OF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
SEVEN, THE KAVANAUGH STYLE
LAST-MINUTE COORDINATED SMEAR
TACTICS THAT THEY THOUGHT WORK,
THEY HAVE NOT BEEN SUCCESSFUL.
EIGHT, THIS ENTIRE CHARADE
CEMENTED WE HAVE ALREADY KNOWN
ABOUT THE MOB AND THE MEDIA.
THEY ARE DERANGED.
THEY’RE NOTHING BUT AN EXTENSION
OF THE RADICAL EXTREME
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, SOCIALISTS.
THEY HAVE BEEN ROOTING AGAINST
THIS PRESIDENT EVERY STEP OF THE
WAY.
THIS IS ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE.
NEWS BUSTERS HAS REPORTED THEIR
STUDY.
PRETTY BREATHTAKING.
NETWORK EVENING NEWS, GET THIS,
GAVE 100% NEGATIVE SPIN COVERAGE
OF ALL THE PRESIDENT’S DEFENSE
THAT’S WINNING THE DAY.
AND A 95% POSITIVE SPIN ON, OH,
YOU KNOW, THE CONGENITAL LIAR
AND THE DEMOCRATS’ ARGUMENTS.
DO YOU WANT TO KNOW WHY I CALLED
THE MEDIA THE MOB?
THERE YOU GO.
WITHOUT A DOUBT, ONE OF THE
MOB’S FAVORITE TARGETS HAS BEEN
HARBORED CONSTITUTIONAL LAW
PROFESSOR SCHOLAR
ALAN DERSHOWITZ.
IT’S BEEN BRUTAL.
IT’S BEEN VICIOUS.
HE IS A DEMOCRAT.
HE IS QUITE KNOWLEDGEABLE ABOUT
OUR CONSTITUTION.
HE’S BEEN A PROFESSOR AT HARVARD
FOR A LONG TIME.
LISTEN TO WHAT, BECAUSE HE DARE
HAVE A DIFFERENT OPINION, LISTEN
TO WHAT THEY SAY.
>> WE HAVE THE NEW CATECHISM OF
THE NEW LEGAL ORACLE,
DERSHOWITZ.
A LEGAL CATECHISM THAT NOBODY
HAS EVER EMBRACED OF STATURE.
>> I DON’T THINK HARVARD IS
HAPPY TONIGHT.
>> THE ONLY THING THAT ALAN
LOVES MORE THAN THE LAW IS THE
TV CAMERA.
>> IT’S AMAZING WHEN YOU LOSE
YOUR HAIR WHAT HAPPENS.
[LAUGHTER]
>> THIS IS UN-AMERICAN.
THIS IS WHAT YOU HEAR FROM
STALIN.
MUSSOLINI.
HITLER PAID ALL THE AFFAIR TRAIN
PEOPLE WHO RATIONALIZED AND IN S
CASES GENOCIDE BASED
ON WHAT WAS IN THE PUBLIC
INTEREST.
>> Sean: MUSSOLINI, HITLER,
GENOCIDE?
ALAN DERSHOWITZ IS DRIVING THE
MOB OFF A CLIFF BECAUSE OF